- All right, everybody.
Let's wrap things up with one last story
to bring you joy, hopefully.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
Like I mentioned earlier,
today kicks off Women's History Month.
To celebrate, I want you
to meet a 19 year old
from Belgium who just made
history as the youngest woman
to fly solo around the world.
In fact, she broke the
two Guinness world records
on the journey.
It took her five months traveling
through 41 countries across 32,300 miles.
Geez, let's say hi to Zara.
(audience cheering)
Hi, Zara!
- Hi, Kelly.
- Oh my god, this is a tremendous feat!
So why you wanna do it?
- So I'd always thought
flying around the world,
it would just be the coolest thing
like the most amazing adventure.
I'm really lucky both
my parents are pilots.
So I grew up around aviation
but I always assumed
that it'd be too dangerous,
too complicated, too expensive.
So I never really thought about it.
And then I was finishing high school
and I think that's when I realized
with that attitude I'm not going anywhere.
So I said, "I'm doing
this a hundred percent."
So I planned my route,
grabbed a pen and a world map
and kind of drew a line around the world
where I wanted to go.
And then spent ages
looking for sponsorship,
emailed 500 companies.
They basically all said no
but then a Bulgarian
man phoned me up one day
and he said, "Zara, how are you doing?"
And, "I wanna help you out."
- Oh, that's amazing.
See it hit home with somebody.
That's really cool.
So it was quite a journey
but you faced many setbacks, right?
- I did.
So I left in August
and it was supposed to take three months
but it actually took five
months and it was pretty tough.
Amazing.
Flying over Iceland I think
was the most incredible moment
when I saw an active
volcano from the plane.
Then the hardest moment
for me was probably
flying over California.
At the time, there were
some pretty bad wildfires
and it got to a point
where I was flying along
and I could just smell
the smoke in the cockpit
and not see a single thing
because it was just so heavy.
And later on the toughest
moment was definitely Siberia
for me.
I was flying in minus
31 degrees Fahrenheit.
I was super, super remote
and just really intimidating
because if the engine quit,
suddenly I'm stuck hours away
from rescue in a really cold climate.
But it was incredible,
the people were amazing
and I couldn't have asked
for a better opportunity.
- That's awesome.
What a cool adventure that you went on.
I mean, this would make an
amazing movie, just saying.
Thank you so much Zara.
Continue success in the aviation field!
I'm liking your post right now.
That's not all though.
I wanna tell you our season
long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of G2, the go to pen
of the Kelly Clarkson show,
want to honor ultimate
overachiever like you.
I can't imagine actually anybody better
to give this money to.
So they're gonna write
you a check for $1000.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering drowns out Zara)
All right. All right.
- Thank you.
- Hey, if you ever, if you
ever wanna do another cool trip
like that hit me up, I'll help you out.
That's so cool what you're doing.
I just wanna see the pictures from it.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you. You can be
the passenger in the back.
- [Kelly Clarkson] All
right, good luck Zara!